with just a few days to go before the  World Cup kicks off in Brazil hundreds  of thousands gyrated to the beat in  Berlin at the carnival of cultures amid  tropical temperatures Brazil was the  focus of this year's event  Wow it's like in Brazil isn't at 32° I  think I'm from Brazil and she's German  it's just great  perfect perfect dance groups from many  different immigrant groups in Berlin  took part in the parade the annual  festival was launched in 1996 and has  taken place ever since the event  celebrates the city's diversity and  takes a stand against nationalism and  racism I think this exists only in  Berlin if I didn't live here I'd come  here to see it organizers expected  around 700,000 spectators and they did  their best to ignore the blistering heat